Sí buenos días Nos encontramos en este
momento con
alexanders Aunque Michel es un ciudadano
de esta ciudad de jarquín donde estamos
en este momento pero ha vivido en
Latinoamérica en Guatemala y por eso
habla español y nos va a conceder esta
entrevista en español Muchas gracias
Alexander por estar hoy con nosotros
Muchas gracias Eren a su actuación Hola
Alexander dónde estabas tú cuando empezó
esta guerra y cómo te enteraste de que
había empezado este conflicto esta nueva
fase de la conflicto con Rusia en este
día y yo y mi familia estaba durmiendo
en nuestra casa aquí en y nos
despertaron los sonidos de las
explosiones y en la mañana nosotros
empezamos
nuestros muletas de emergencia compramos
comida en tiendas
y estaba muy difícilmente creer en esta
situación Sí realmente sí una situación
muy difícil
Cómo ha cambiado tu ciudad harking en
este año de guerra
ahora
mi ciudad
está es muy destruido por explosiones y
es muy triste verlo porque harky es la
ciudad de hermoso de industrial de
donde tenemos mucho felicidad mucho
mucho estudiantes
mucho cultura todo tenemos todo pero
ahora no Ahora solo esperamos a todos
mejores
tiempos mejores
qué ha sido para ti en todo este periodo
lo más difícil lo más duro de este
conflicto a nivel personal
para mí personal más duro esta
separación de mi familia
ahora mi esposa y mi hijo que tiene 9
años Ellos viven en Polonia porque
empresas donde yo trabajo
Tiene muchas oficinas y en otros países
y oficinas de Polonia ellos invitó
nuestras esposas y hijos
a Polonia sí los dieron apartamentos
todo lo que ellos necesitaban todo y por
eso quiero decir muchas gracias a la
empresa
todos Muchas gracias por ayudar
muy duro no poder ver a tu familia en
todo este tiempo
Qué piensas cuando Oyes una sirena o
incluso un bombardeo en tu ciudad en qué
piensas en qué haces si de ser verdad y
yo no hago nada porque yo ya tengo
costumbre sobre este sonido y solo si
escucho uno bombardeos sí y yo escribo o
yo llamo a mis amigos y preguntas si
todos bien o no con ellos nada más
entonces yo
es costumbre no poderlo explicar es todo
tu ciudad ha sido muy afectada también a
nivel económico era un importante centro
Industrial pero muchas empresas se han
ido Tú crees que este daño es permanente
que estas empresas volverán que el daño
llevará mucho tiempo en
recuperarse
Estoy seguro que después de guerra todos
los empresas volverán a harkid y más más
empresas más cambien porque harky es muy
grande muy fuerte ciudad y
después de guerra él va a estar más
grande más fuerte más hermoso y
va a estar más Industrial vas a ver
Sí cómo ves tu futuro
yo voy a estar aquí yo voy a esperar
cuando vamos a ganar en esa Guerra y voy
a ayudar a nuestro militar este si
necesitan
Muchas gracias Alexander por esta
entrevista que nos has dado y
desde aquí se entiende muchísimo la
emoción Irene el testimonio ha sido
realmente
conmovedor pero quisiera aprovechar
estos últimos minutos que nos quedan
Irene luego volveremos por supuesto
contigo llegaste a Ucrania a poco tiempo
del inicio de la guerra casi un año
recorrido el país has escuchado
testimonios como este y muchos otros que
nos ponen las pieles de gallina que te
deja este año de presencia en el
territorio en esta guerra que marca el
mundo
pues efectivamente me deja una profunda
tristeza hay las personas de este país
sus vidas se han congelado de alguna
forma y no hay que olvidar que antes de
esta guerra el mundo vivió una pandemia
por tanto hay generaciones acá sobre
todo de jóvenes que realmente no están
pudiendo avanzar en no están pudiendo
desarrollarse normalmente como como
sería
lo habitual por este conflicto en este
momento y esto Quizás es un aspecto que
será una cicatriz que durará por mucho
tiempo y tendrá consecuencias también en
la posguerra en otros contextos en otros
países estos todavía se ve 20-25 años
después todavía las las cicatrices de la
guerra son muy presentes y el daño que
hacen estos conflictos la violencia
los odios que
que generan permanecen por mucho tiempo
esto creo que es lo que a mí me preocupa
realmente más en este momento